New York has been this state hardest hit
by covert 19 and it was also battered on
Monday by bad weather health care
workers had to contend with heavy rain
and high winds at this emergency tent
facility in Central Park and they were
not the only ones weathering a storm in
Washington US President Donald Trump
faced criticism over his handling of the
crisis at his Daily Press briefing the
president surprised journalists with
what some are calling a propaganda video
defending his response then he went on
the offensive remember this everything
we did I was criticized because I was
too early if I waited longer it would
have been you would have incurred if I
went way early if I went three months
earlier I would have been criticized you
know criticized for being way too early
I think I've educated a lot of people as
to the press and I would love to be able
to say that we have a very honest press
Trump said his administration was
finalizing a plan to reopen the US
economy
when questioned on who would decide on
relaxing lockdown rules Trump said he
would be calling the shots it's a
decision for the President of the United
States now with that being said we're
gonna work with the states because it's
very important several state governors
on the east and west coasts are
discussing the best way to open their
economies and ease stay at home orders
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo seemed to
suggest he thought it should be largely
up to individual states not the
president he left it to the states to
close down and that was a state-by-state
decision without any guidance really he
took the position that it was a States
decision and then the states were
responsible for purchasing supplies etc
with infection numbers in New York
beginning to Plateau the calls to loosen
the lockdown are getting louder but the
road back to normalcy will be a long one
to tell us more I'm joined by DW
correspondent Oliver zealot in
Washington DC Oliver as we saw Trump
defended his response to the coronavirus
reaction what did you make of what he
said well this is one of those press
conference clear to be remembered a
highly unusual press conference with a
very very angry
president Trump lashing out against his
critics against the media he also
insulted journalists in the room you
just heard his sound buy it there so
really strongly trying to defend himself
and I was a very special moment in that
press conference when the White House
showed a campaign style video where they
actually defended the handling president
Trump's handling of that pandemic and
this is one of those videos that you
would actually see on a campaign rally
but not on a government press conference
of course so it really shows that
President Trump got under pressure u.s.
networks later called that video a
propaganda video and that happened after
Anthony Fauci president Trump's leading
expert in infectious diseases indirectly
criticized President Trump saying that
many lives could have been saved if the
government had acted earlier that's
right there's been some controversy
surrounding a Trump's response a to
director excuse me to dr. Anthony Fauci
can you tell us a little bit more about
that right and that controversy began
after those Falchi remarks that I just
mentioned and today President Trump
retweeted a tweet where someone called
for firing Antoni Falchi and then there
were additional media reports that Trump
was actually planning to do exactly that
firing his coronavirus export expert
excuse me which he then later rejected
as fake news so big controversy here
leading up to that press conference
Lilly later Anthony Falchi was trying to
put that into perspective in that press
conference he said he had a bad choice
of words he also said that Trump acted
when he told him to with regards to the
shutdown of course but with regards to
the import
assessment that he made that lives could
have been saved had the government acted
earlier he stayed on message and it is a
very serious situation for Trump you can
see that in his response as well the
election here in the United States is
coming up and President Trump really got
on the defensive so as we've seen that
back and forth between Falchi and Trump
can you tell us how the situation in the
United States has been developing all
right so there's another debate right
now going on and that is about when to
reopen and who's in charge of reopening
the economy is that the governor's is
that the president's so total of nine US
states is now trying to organize
themselves trying to lift those
stay-at-home orders New York is one of
them they have seen a dip in
hospitalizations over the last days but
Andrew Cuomo New York's governor is
stressing that the situation is still
very bad that there are 2,000 new cases
every day and that you have to be very
careful when reopening the economy
warning about a backlash correspondent
Oliver salad in Washington thank you
very much